hey everybody welcome back coffee on a
Tuesday and vlog 53 here's a story and a
theory in the 15th century a dynastic
Civil War known today as the War of the
Roses resulted in the annihilation of
virtually every member of the British
aristocracy in the end it was Henry
Tudor distant cousin of the Lancaster
family who in 1485 ascended to become
King Henry the seventh now to keep order
Henry has to build himself an
aristocracy the only problem is all the
Royals are dead so what does he do he
pulls people up from the petty nobility
the lower classes and by introducing
social mobility to Western society he
initiates what is arguably the most
important movement in all of human
history modernity it might be hard to
imagine since it's so much a part of our
lives today but before this social
stratification was rigidly fixed you
were born into a class and you stayed
there for life and as the hierarchy was
determined by God people literally
thought it was impossible to change
their status the providential plan was
the providential plan did old Henry know
what he was doing
no he was acting out of necessity but
all of a sudden what the public thought
was impossible was happening right in
front of their eyes a massive change in
culture for many a positive one and
because it was so positive people began
to reorganize the rules of their
symbolic reality to accommodate I talk
more about symbolic reality in vlog 46
time essentially it's the symbols and
logics by which we live our lives for
the first time in history the word
nation became synonymous with the word
people people began to govern themselves
make their own laws and God steadily
lost influence in both political and
human affairs but in the midst of all
these positive changes something very
dark and very troubling was stirring
beneath the surface the world's very
first mental institution place called
bedlam in London began to take on more
and more patients cries so hideous and
so great shook the inner walls according
to one resident what was happening
well the widespread psychological
diseases we know today as manic
depression and schizophrenia were being
diagnosed
for the very first time in feudal
England a society where your lot in life
was ordained by God personal crises what
undermines these illnesses were uncommon
you can't really fail at what you are
because your identity in a system like
that was secured at birth in the new
system the system of social mobility and
ambition another word that enters common
usage at that time choice becomes a part
of the equation the responsibility falls
off God shoulders and onto your suddenly
you can fail at becoming what you want
to become with no one to blame but you
this was the bittersweet upshot of the
new modernity while many were reaping
the positive rewards of climbing the
social ladder others were plunging into
personal crises by failing to do so no
longer secured by the clasp of your
birth personal identity needed something
to balance out the dark side of
modernity enter Will Shakespeare when
new worlds are birthed from bolder
failings new logics fill the vacuum from
pieces made of the old it takes an
imagination of a truly great stature to
see and think through in essence create
the principles by which the rest of us
can live our lives in the new world that
kind of person the rarest of rare we
call genius around 1593 at the height of
this cultural upheaval Shakespeare
writes Romeo and Juliet in this play we
have basically the rulebook
the best definition of what we know
today as love no text before this
elevates love to such an incredible
height no text gives it the same quality
and value in language the most important
of symbolic systems Shakespeare's mind
was an extraordinarily close
coordination with the world around him
he could see what was happening to the
people of London the city like most
cities played host to a number of the
mentally disabled most of whom had
nowhere to go and so remain homeless
Shakespeare sees it all and we get
amazing diagnostic insights into these
conditions and plays like King Lear and
Handel in Romeo and Juliet he offers a
solution love the poet writes in sonnet
116 is the star to every wandering bark
in other words the north star to every
wandering mind Shakespeare effectively
establishes love's transformative power
a power for the average citizen that it
did not have before this kind of love is
identity affirmed
find a Romeo or Juliet is to find
someone who will reinforce your own
positive identity as a person in luck
and extremely powerful symbolic logic
its power evidenced by the sheer turmoil
of heartbreak and Shakespeare being a
writer for the common man makes it
something that is applicable to anyone
rich or poor wherever you stand in the
now chaotic social hierarchy in essence
and as you know it Shakespeare
invented love down the generations we
can see the impact Shakespeare has done
more to define the current reality still
than any other person or group of people
since he brought the culture into his
mind at a critical historical moment
dissected it thought through the logic
and expressed it for all of us in
achingly beautiful first now you may
wonder about texts like the Odyssey or
Plato's symposium or Dante's Vita Nuova
because there are accounts in those of
love or it may nag at you that if what I
said is true that love is somehow a sham
as for those texts it's perhaps worth it
to say that both affection and love were
around before Shakespeare but the
quality of love as we conceive of it
today the Hollywood nosov it the
applicability to all the identity of
firming power is I think what
Shakespeare brought into the culture as
for feeling that love is a sham you
shouldn't what you feel today when
you're in love is completely and totally
real and the identity of firming power
of it is real too
this is how symbolic reality works it
changes over time and what's real to you
and the culture at large is what's real
Shakespeare is not a genius because of
his intelligence he's a genius because
of his powerful imagination his symbolic
imagination his ability to bound through
steps of emerging logics and work out
new conclusions what's incredible is
that we all possess the exact same
ability that's the spectacular interplay
between culture and the mind the latter
can revolutionize the former we have
only to take those symbols back into our
mind and like the great man think them
through again
I have to thank my sociology professor
from bu Leah Greenfeld who introduced me
to these ideas of symbolic reality and
this crazy theory about Shakespeare um
I'll put a link in the description where
you can read more from her she's really
truly incredible also don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already and
follow me on tumblr or Twitter links in
the description I will see you next time